here we go ten seconds until kickoff
okay here we go
119 players little over 1,800 average
rating give me this ticker okay I'm
gonna have a space advantage pawn push I
do a 5 I don't want to castle just yet
actually I want to keep by the H file
open okay my opponent is coming at me
here
give me the H file I could take this
pawn maybe after I turn my knight in
here a knight is probably gonna get -
whoa this is dangerous
I could take here next pretty much no
matter what and now it's coming with the
Czech Queen here it's close to mate very
close to me that might be mate it is
gonna be made I get my get my pick rook
g8 or h7 back determined - who's up
there
Anton's squared Oh watch out for the
scholars me 29 that was a quick that was
a quick game right there
Oh who's up there cap I just saw cap out
of nowhere the cap stir here we go cap
is in town oh man I think I'm going to
be chasing I'm gonna be chasing hang on
hang on here hang on hit that hit this
pond he's uh he's weak Castle I'm still
hitting the pond meetin one Queen here I
want to I want to get it I want to rule
the dark squares I do that I'm a knight
twice
I don't even know am I gonna be try I
think night here or something traps me
my queen okay I'm on the knight again
and I do this stop I don't know I just I
should probably castle right cuz Mike
the Queen is opposite my king right that
is when you want a castle right there
whenever you see okay hang on hang on
for a second let's get my Brooks finally
doing something just friends sitting
here all game I just want to take that
pawn I want to actually keep the Queen's
on the board can you believe it can you
believe it believe it man I want to keep
the Queen ease on the board I'm on the
night I have to drop back I want to jump
in my knight right here probably no
matter what killer check on c3 oh this
is gonna be devastating on the Queen
break this open pawn takes it's made on
B to get the a file soon they're down on
time back to tournament eight eight six
six five windmill very fast very fast
player and knows all about the fishing
pole all about it okay man hang on hang
on
he killed very quickly I should throw my
knight in there I should throw my knight
right in there okay I'm on this you
can't defend that you got to run over
here with your King I can't be fun I'm
on this pond I got that pond Oh opponent
was going for a quick quick kill
rooks my rooks doing something right Oh
Knight here I know I'm defending with my
bishop as well it's back pawn push I
should be doing a pawn push I have this
defended my rook is defending that okay
how can I put put to you okay let's get
these pawns going let's keep going
look here where does that mean where
does that mean I better watch out I
don't get made it why did I even do that
move okay I'm on the bishop mother
bishop um okay I'll go for this oh okay
I free heard forgetting that the bishop
was what was the bishop doing what am I
trying to say I can't I don't know how
to formulate my thoughts just move how
would that that's the advice to myself
just move would you keep pawns on dark
look for the main there I should have
done that much sooner where's the main
King here where's the main I was writing
with my King there I was ready no I
would have been stalemate no stalemate
there down in time back to tournament
2016 12
I couldn't there he is what is he's he's
down here with eight a hoe back to
tournament hang on 2016 16 11 the chief
the chief is in town mr. Peter Griffin
Peter Griffin there you go there you are
quick kill
Anton Square tactic bring bring the
Queen out oh yeah oh man my knight okay
let's pin their Knight let's see how
they like it
let's see how they like it get out of
that pin okay I have something it's like
a reverse fishing pole in a way what is
that nobody knows about that one a
reverse fishing pole get my queen out to
a floor it could happen on this side too
I'm okay Knight takes Knight I'll just
push my pawns over here let's just push
them
just take my bishop right here tricky
night I know he's not around I still
have play over here there's got to be
play over there right okay okay now I
got to do something let's retreat now
maintain both my bishops are pointing
right at my opponent's King pawn takes
and just pawn push I don't think I even
need to castle what's my opponent doing
Oh No
I'm always fearful to come yes yeah
whenever my opponent doesn't move all of
a sudden and they're not moving okay
maybe they were just thinking think tank
can I get the a file open up or the B
file any file really I want to get it
the King any file any file pawn push of
King here everything is crumbling here
no matter what
Bishop check I should have done this is
gonna be brutal that's gonna be main
double check where's the mate they're
down on time doesn't matter thirty-two
thirty twenty six nineteen I need a
cushion
I need a cushion I'm not I'm not I don't
even have a cushion I need some okay
what do I need I need to have a lead and
I don't have a lead here okay let's
weasel over here Knight this is where
you want to be right over here before I
castle so I could first make use of f8
what's what's going what's the story
with that let's go and reverse for a
second I have a plan you're gonna have
to believe me on that one trade dark
square Bishop for one that's first first
plan throughout my nights on dark
squares a second plan watch over this
square is a third plan okay pawn push I
just take maybe I can make use of this
I'm doing this to stop Knight stuff it
can also do okay the Knights coming in
here it's happening my knight might be
taken soon some exchange sack there you
go now my king is gonna go here and
we're gonna have a queen trade if that
happen
we're having it so now this pond is
gonna fall this night is boxed out this
bishop is silly so let's see if I could
not drop a rock but first things first
let's don't drop a rock that's the first
order of business they're down on time
I'm not afraid of that night should I be
it's a passed pawn my nights gonna be
really good
oh I dropped that pond let me just get
this guy out of here oh oh that's a
problem
hang on it's a little scary make sure
that Bishop is out of here make sure
that bishop is gone you need to go get
this guy pushing I push I queen with
check what a detail right there
not so important but okay that's mate
next no it's not the king could have
went somewhere else doesn't matter 38 42
38 32 28 oh yeah who's this who is this
somebody does 12
caro-kann why me why am i allowing this
I should have went for like the fantasy
oh I should have okay I could jump in
here I'm on the pond May that's a quick
mate I'll take it Oh fifty to forty to
fifty two forty two thirty Ian here we
go 20 minutes there is a lot of time
remaining whoa look at that H fun Wow
is he crazy that is the craziest H pond
ever let's shut this Bishop down and
make sure he stays shut down and develop
pieces towards the center this nights
gonna jump in here now back up I want to
kick him away one day one day I'll
Castle I'm okay over here it's that part
gonna fall
let's open stuff up Queens off I love it
I want the Queens off no no that would
have been okay let me throw in a check
on g3 why didn't I consider that I have
my bishop around to watch over for my
Kings side that's why I'm not too
concerned about castling this section it
was just my night it have some concern
my opponent is
moving throw a check in and then take
and then take here am I missing anything
all forks maybe on fg3
oh yeah that's a free piece incoming
foot no it's not yeah no I got a fork
it's gonna happen right here I got my
pick I'm gonna go after the one that I
could um get for free actually is gonna
be lost next soon enough take my bishop
and I recapture with the check and my
knight is saved let's do this pawn push
I want to get rid of that night huh I
almost missed that would have been at
least for petrol get rid of that tricky
Knight
you need to go you definitely need to go
I should have taken that pawn with check
here no matter what how much time she
feels like there should be mate may here
no matter what I believe it is that's
mate game back to tournament 68 56 54 18
minutes a lot of time a lot of time
remaining here we go um okay they're not
really starting Oh Oh back to tournament
they're down they resigned 7756 are
what's that one where they just didn't
start up and you get the automatic win
after 15 seconds either way I got the W
that's all that's all it's about right
here
I almost sort of mouse slipped that one
I'm not throwing my age pond down there
and looked exciting when my opponent did
it to me Bishop check hang on Bishop
check centralized the Queen she's
hitting everything isn't she the bishop
out queenside castle I think I want a
sack I should have taken this pawn now
I'll take it it's with the check I feel
like there should be a main soon it's my
bishops and stuff bishop here I'm
hitting the rook where does the rook go
this is lethal look at these guys are
here they're monsters they're monsters
I'll get the exchange
centralize my bishop trade King on the
dark square they resigned back to
tournaments 97 97 72 I have a cushion I
might need that okay
17 we're not even halfway quick resign
what's happening why are we having these
quick resign errs I got a play against
the mayor right now the mayor of the zoo
here you gotta play against the mayor
all of a sudden okay I still I'm
thinking about it of course still I'm
thinking about it okay
Newcastle let me castle that's okay I'm
gonna take that light-square weaknesses
night here avoid the exchange kick the
night away and jump at night in here
it's lethal
remove the defender of f3 and it's game
over oh that was a slick move I feel
like there should be made even with like
a nightmare bishop get rid of this and
then this and then jump in here we go
deadly Fork matin to thread the Queen
has to give herself up she didn't give
herself up that's me back to terminal
127 9070 oh I had a bunch of luck I have
12 games in but like four of them were
designers weren't they
okay 16 16 the Scandinavian okay let's
get my bishop out and maybe go for a
quick kill I try something sneaky I get
that Bishop real quick okay let me
castle clean this pond could be taken I
probably want to do just a pawn push let
me do this and then undermine that night
somehow can I do that I want to get here
just gonna take grab there with my
bishop and then my knight
I don't know
okay yeah let's try it and then just
take something take the rook take that
rook and then get on this dog and it'll
somehow back up clean here am I gonna
land in any Forks oh I just dropped that
I'm down a full rook no not I'm down a
full piece Queen here it's not happening
I want to get their main threat how is
it defendant not so easily that's made a
hole man that was a tough one to defend
surprisingly with that minimal material
that was a very weak diagonal pointing
right at that king
let's halfway point less than 15 I don't
know that you could really maintain this
pawn on e5 yeah this is crumbling now
this is crumbling oh boy pac-man mode
pac-man mode hang on to that pin I like
that pin okay this is I have a giant
wave of pawns here a giant wave of pawns
just killed that actually know something
was scaring me right there did you know
this could you tell by that sound you
just heard this was nervous I was
fearful like the Queen coming out here
that's not even a good move though I
just want to get this tsunami of pawns
rolling and they're gonna get rolling
you can't stop them every every move
like is coming with tempo
it seems pawn push discovery on a
cleaner I'm hitting everything hitting
everything pawn push is this check watch
out for me here I have this covered
just get rid of that and right here I
still have this covered it's a little
scary
I just want to make sure he's out of
there get rid of that dark square bishop
I don't care about capturing that pot on
c2 just want to remove any pinning now
I'll take now I'll go here and then just
push this pawn cut off the Queen's
defense of the rook watch out for me
let's check right here defend stuff
defends everything now that's going to
be a trade soon enough
okay pawn push pawn push they don't have
any time back to tournament 167 139 108
12 minutes remaining
okay efore what's with these
Scandinavian players center counter okay
I think this could be an issue it's not
going over this the 1 and the 1 5 minute
game I don't know if that's really
working Oh pawn push okay this is a
problem now for my opponent that that
Bishop is an issue this is a big issue
this pawn isn't going anywhere I want to
reinforce this Queen e2 his pawns gonna
fall 90 for Bishop g5 I want to get to
this Square my knight is allowed to get
there there's gonna be a serious problem
let's stop Knight f4 first just
restricting stuff keep my bishop on this
diagonal no need to go elsewhere and
stop this b4 advance if a 4 then B 4 is
difficult there's no there's no problems
now remove the dark square Bishop get my
night on g5 castle my rook on you when I
look on 80 when I want my rook around
once I'm Castle to watch over this point
this is only so the only weak point I
might have and then just crash through
here you can't defend it actually I want
to go here for I had a fork for how many
moves let me take this 23 seconds
okay here next no let's get at this pawn
I could have taken with my bishop but
let's go here okay what's the what's the
story here grab this pawn I guess let's
do this first I'd rather get this pawn I
think okay now we're close to mate the
knight has to block oh I almost dropped
something there tried again me I get
that like going here grab here next 18
seconds this game just isn't gonna
finish here no matter what
just grab upon anything anything at all
it's just not gonna finish back to
tournament 187 whoa whoa wait wait wait
whoa 189 189 187 I'm two points back
when two points back that guy must have
got some quick designers to pawn push
span in the center with the tempo here
we go and give up the center yeah I got
a pawn looking for a fork on f2 got it
castle soon they're gonna resign let me
save my knight they're not allowing me
to save my knight so easily why'd I drop
that pawn Knight takes bishop takes
there still defending that dropping this
but my knight I'll probably rescued now
he is gonna be rescued if there's ever a
bishop check I could just block here no
problem
rook check is gonna be difficult to
defend let's get my bishop here to stop
the King from going up and my other
rooked I mean I should have just castled
on that night twice I almost missed that
was already on that
let's check take here next that's me I
forgot I was covering that eye that
square that dark square back to sermon
209 207 9 minutes remaining
Knight 3 2 1 this is close 209 to 207
two-point lead
from chess master chess master has a two
point lead here here we go
let's get f4 Knight f3 and open up the F
file and target f7 pressure on this pond
twice if this pawn isn't around I'm
gonna play d4 most likely I might just
play d4 right away
no actually I'm now because there might
be some tactics on this diagonal after
my clean recaptures I think I would have
wanted to capture with my clean I want
my knight on f5 and I get that in there
capture it's my clean otherwise there's
a skewer with Bishop g4 rook takes
Bishop here is a problem Bishop here I
play Queen here this pond is indirectly
in a pin trying to remove this Knight
Bishop here seems like a candidate move
I also want to jump into d5 and also
just kick this night away this is gonna
win material now the knight has to move
that's check I just step side step that
still same thing here it's not resolved
successfully pawn push I just take
Bishop move one of these guys are gonna
fall 17 seconds could have made here
also if the bishop moves it's just me
that'd be nice mate threat main threat
matin one too close to it there's no
time bishop here Queen here and then
there's a sack actually main to threat
this is this is more direct rook takes
pawn and then mate on h6 Queen f8 is
probably the best defense actually
wouldn't be a defense to to 227 209 I
guess he's ready to win he's ready to
win seven minutes remaining is it gonna
come down and what is it gonna come down
to
we're gonna see about that what is it
gonna come down to who could get that
last game in if we both keep winning on
that Bishop you take this and then bring
Michael no I'm gonna grab that central
pawn it's a free pawn he's a freebie
just run away and then expand in the
center I have this square covered
I was ready to just play here you got
the Queens off Bishop here yeah no I
think I want to kick that night away get
that night away and I'm gonna try
something sneaky this is the sneaky move
Bishop c5 watch out for Bishop c5 I'm
also just on c4 threatening to win
another pawn so this is not just sneaky
but probably best okay so the Queen's
are often loved two pawns I have the
bishop pair and I don't know that I need
to even castle I just dropped upon hang
on I do want to castle castle I want to
get in b5 okay never mind I want to do
b5 because I'm this diagonal seemed
appealing but more directly let's just
get developed as soon as possible my
knight wants to be on f2 my rooks want
to work and I need a flight square as
well that's the last thing I'm on the
bishop Knight here seems very strong I
was right just play there and give up
the exchange okay so it's still the
bishop pair material times are about
even what am i doing to make progress
here
anything good doesn't seem like it let's
get out of tricks should probably just
taken that night or something the
Knights gonna play here or is he I
didn't know what that move does you know
that feeling sometimes you just don't
know I got the rook I got the rook now I
know I want now I know what I want to do
I want to just trade secure my bishops
position now there's back rank issues
that Knights do not have good homes
they have no homes and I don't I can't
get that to the entry points until that
night moves but he's not moving I'm
gonna resign they're not resigning hey
you know I should just pushed instead of
defending pushed this night away and
then double up and then look for made on
the back rank they resigned or they're
down on time 249 247 212 less than five
minutes remaining if we get paired up
that is going to be the biggest game
around are we gonna get paired up
let's see what our with all these
Scandinavian players Bishop g4 is what
Nikolas would have played who knows what
I'm talking about the one oh I just
Queen there would have picked up the
bishop let's grab this part now I'm up
no I'm I'm on the Queen takes okay
deadly fork I'm you know do I want to
take that yeah I do
open stuff up I have the rook let's go
my bishop wants to play he still wants
to play but my knight wants to square in
reaction to this advance open up this
file bishop tanks now this problem this
Bishop is toast
he's toast this is going to be very
painful I'm pretty sure my bishop is
gonna be hitting everything everything
there Knight is having trouble doing
stuff I should have played here sooner
so I have a fork get rid of that Knight
land a fork that is definitely a fork
right there
clean is dead are they gonna resign
they're not resigned if they did resign
back determined to 69 to 67 three
minutes remaining I could only get one
more in for sure and it's not against
that guy so ah
what do we have is he gonna move if he
doesn't move I gotta win this might be
good it'd be good 15 seconds come on
call it call it people at chess cube
quickly 15 seconds is up oh they had a
move
what are they they were teasing me don't
tease me ah man you should just don't
ever do that attempt never do that again
Castle drop Age 3 okay am i dropping
something okay man I have to go home for
just a minute just a minute I'm gonna
Castle queenside now let's hang into
that pond he's important pawns are
important
remember that remember that pawns are
important it's come over in it look at
the what do you call this look at all
these silly okay can i target something
finally I push this pawn I don't I don't
even know what I'm doing with that move
what am I even doing could we open stuff
up finally okay I'm ready to be trapped
or something pawns just gonna push why
what am i doing I can't make 27 seconds
just look to the clock and try and win
that way I guess watch out for Forks
Snyder's ready to hammer me he's ready
to hammer me right here on b6 of
two-minute warning that's a tough pin to
get out of you can't even get out of
that yeah you could okay I have to think
about clock this game is not gonna
finish I need to just do anything I'm
just doing that just burn time just to
burn time anything they're gonna to
capture my palm time burners anything
this game is just not gonna finish it's
just not gonna finish I think I need
time to come off back determine 280-300
nine oh I can't win or could I win no I
can't win he's got a cushion even if I
get twenty he has to drop back let's see
let's see let's see this just isn't
gonna work is it it just it's not gonna
work I need a I need so many quick wins
it's just not happening could that
knight move or something it's not moving
man it's not happening it's definitely
not happening a key that's thrown a
check in there
okay this is kind of working actually
it's not Queen takes is fine the rook
would take first 38 seconds or 33
seconds can I get on this diagonal again
I did it earlier is that not gonna move
pileup on the knight can I get on that
diagonal right here where's the main 17
seconds it's impossible natan once right
oh don't run away
where's the main oh I had to make it to
or something
oh they're calling it their cognate
they're calling it or are they
I saw the thing come up second place oh
man I couldn't cut him Wow yeah 309 I
think yeah
even if I won to 97 and then 307 I don't
you could only go up 20 at most I
thought I'm pretty sure all right 20
games in I had 20 games in as well
252 192
whoa all right good games Oh crazy game
crazy tournament